comme vous le voyez à mes cernes moi je
suis un mec qui dort plutôt bien j'ai
pas vous mais moi depuis tout petit je
suis un très grand à sonia qui vont vous
donner un ordre d'idée je fais en
moyenne une insomnie toutes les nuits je
n'arrive pas à dormir je fais toujours
les mêmes trucs inutiles déjà j'essaye
toutes les positions possibles du corps
humain à la c'est bien je regarde des
trucs à la con sur le net je bois
de l'eau shopi
je bois de l'eau chez vivi boit de l'eau
en zambie j'essaie de me faire croire
que je lis un livre alors qu'en fait je
suis pas du tout concentré je combats
pendant une heure un moustique qui
n'existe pas c'était des tâches
je crois avoir l'idée du siècle alors je
l'écris je la relis c'est de la pure
merde je la jette alors je retourne sur
le net plutôt les gens qui ont un bon
sommeil
parfois ils osent se plaindre avec ce
genre de remarque moi je retrouve du
coup je fatigue est trop dormir j'ai
envie de dire il ya quand même pire
comme problème disons que sur l'échelle
à des problèmes les plus graves dans le
monde
on n'est pas sur un top 3 1 oui les gens
qui n'ont pas de problèmes de sommeil
il aime bien donner des petits conseils
moi je vais pas vous endormir
messieurs ne pense à rien allez je pense
à rien c'est parti je pense à rien je
pense à rien à temps mais là je pense au
fait de penser à rien impossible
alors pour éviter les insomnies il
paraît qu'il faut pas regarder de
l'écran ou moins une heure avant d'aller
dormir et franchement chaque soir
j'essaye de le faire aller une heure
avant de dormir j'arrête at ele gerald
ford
allez j'arrête le téléphone
quand je fais une insomnie je suis
énervé de pas dormir alors je vénère
mais j'ai personne contre qui m'énervait
c'est assez ridicule à samsung pas dans
ma maison tu dors hockey à dormir chaque
année des milliers d'ouvriers sont
frappés à cause d'insomnies soute et les
envoyer vos plumes pour les rembourser
en plus il y avait un truc qui est sûr
c'est que cette parenté n'est avant que
tu vas réussir à t'endormir impossible
on a tous que ce prof chiant au collège
qui nous en or mais en trois secondes à
chacun de ses cours mais des fois je me
dis ce prof la mine de rien il pourrait
être une bonne solution contre
l'insomnie
allô monsieur bouchard a oui ou et
norman thavaud 5e b en 99 ou et vous
pouvez me refaire ce petit cours sur la
trigonométrie là bien sûr grand un petit
à la trigonométrie est une branche
parfois je n'arrive pas à dormir parce
que j'ai une chanson à la tête
mais attention c'est pas un petit
morceau cool qui fait plaisir non c'est
toujours deux secondes une chanson pour
y aller je me lève comme changer un peu
les idées barrage pas je regarde la télé
tout de suite une page de pub
oh non j'ai même regardé sur youtube des
vidéos d'hypnose pour s'endormir fait
par des pros et tout alors je trouve le
concept est génial mais sur moi perso ça
n'a pas trop marché simplement vous vous
inviter à écouter ma voix celui qui va
vous faire voyager vers le sommeil est
solidement sur le sol la terre est posée
dans le système solaire chango cela
alors même que déjà alors même que déjà
oui bonsoir j'aimerais une pizza quatre
fromages ouvrez les yeux tranquillement
qui pose dire toi l'achat alors c'est un
peu cruel mais moi quand j'arrive pas à
dormir
j'aime bien réveillé les autres du coup
je me sens moins seul ça me réconforte
et je m'endors c'est psychologique je
sais pas si vous c'est pareil mais moi
avant de dormir j'ai un vieux stock de
systématiquement calculer le nombre
d'heures que je vais avoir le sommeil
si j'avais mon réveil à 8 heures ça me
fait sept heures de sommeil moins 30
minutes pour préparer demain matin plus
le facteur inconnu x qui correspond à
l'insomnie potentiel d'une durée de deux
à quatre heures
résultat mon nombre d'heures de sommeil
sera 2 83 heures de sommeil et bah c'est
toujours autant une mère d'un match toi
tu mérite bien des tubes heures souvent
tu dors pas parce que tu es stressé par
leur qui défilent tu vois ta nuit se
réduire peu à peu du coup en cas
d'insomnie
il paraît qu'il faut pas regarder leurs
seins ce qui est je trouve une torture
allez je vais la radio 10 minutes je me
détends et la triche d'or sera de
puissance dans l'émission nocturne et il
est 3h du matin au nom après cette page
de pub au il existe mille et un
conseils pour mieux dormir mieux général
chacun a ses propres méthodes
moi par exemple je sais que très souvent
je dors pas parce que je réfléchis trop
et parfois juste un proche d'une
personne qui t'aiment peut trouver les
mots pour te rassurer été apaisées et là
forcément tu trouves le sommeil non
matin et nous l'important demain mais tu
veux pas ta vie me sont fous bonjour
qu'est ce que tu vas piqué du nez alors
voilà on les emmerde
peut-être que tu seras viré et alors
peut-être que t'es pas fait pour ce
métier
peut-être côté droit pour devenir
troubadours arrête stop stop je préfère
quand tu me rassures passe c'est c'est
plus rassurant nickel merci bonne nuit
mais c'est pas si mal troubadours
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si
vous avez apprécié soyez cool
mettez un énorme pouce en l'air durant
mes nuits d'insomnie j'ai carrément
écrit une petite fiction qui parle du
sommeil à dessiner à ma chaîne youtube
j'espère que je pourrai bientôt la faire
et vous la montrer et qu'elle vous
plaira
hu a finalement j'ai pas trop de remède
contre l'insomnie mais ce que je peux
faire c'est vous laisser sur un comptage
de moutons petite info bonus si vous
avez aimé mon petit t-shirt que je porte
dans la vidéo eh ben vous pouvez aussi
vous le procurer parce que c'est ma
petite collection de t-shirts que j'ai
lancé me suis fait un petit kiff il ya
plein de chuck différents rapport à mes
vidéos et plein de petits goodies
le lien est dispo dans la description
voilà bonne nuit restait la doudoune de
ma mère que des bons souvenirs